Inferno is directed by Ron Howard and
stars Tom Hanks and Felicity Jones and
is the third film in the Dan Brown
trilogy we've already had da Vinci Code
and angels and demons which were very
well received and now 10 years later we
have the third film that everyone was
really pining for so Robert Langdon
wakes up in a hospital he has severe
memory loss he can't remember the past
48 hours and his nurse Felicity Jones
just so happens to be there when Langdon
gets shot at by an assassin of some kind
and now these two are on the run in
Florence Italy trying to solve a mystery
that involves a plague that could be
unleashed
having something to do with Dante's
Inferno if you want to know how I feel
about the other films I'm very lukewarm
on them I don't really think they needed
another film but there's another book so
now we have another film and this is an
unbelievably dull movie with really the
only person in the entire production
that seems as if they are really trying
being Tom Hanks he's one of the best
actors alive I've loved him in many
movies he was great this year in Sully
but here he is surrounded by a director
a writer and an entire crew that just
doesn't seem to give a I want to
talk about Ron Howard I have liked a lot
of his films Apollo 13 being one of my
favorite films he's made I think he is
an extremely talented director I don't
know what he's doing with this trilogy
they all look like born knock-offs
in fact this one even gives our hero
memory loss everything about this movie
seems like it's trying to be a Bourne
movie with a slightly older protagonist
and it's more of a mystery setting with
a lot of old mythology and things that
are referenced quite often and it sort
of comes off like a cross between a very
dull Jason Bourne and a very bland
national treasure not Indiana Jones not
Laura Croft national treasure that's
where we're at here guys it's those two
things combined to make an experience
that I genuinely could not stand
watching this film looks as if it was
shot four straight to blu-ray the only
thing that's convincing me this is a
theatrical film is the inclusion of
stars like Felicity Jones and Tom Hanks
Ron Howard's direction in this film is
so listless that there's
in a sequence where he completely
forgets about the 180 roll has Tom Hanks
on another woman he's having a
conversation with both on the right side
of the frame as they cut back and forth
between them and our eyes don't move at
all and we are bored to the entire
film feels like that a very shaky
handheld choppa Lee edited mess there
are so many logical inconsistencies as
well like Hanks not being able to
remember the word for coffee but
instantly within the same scene
remembering his gmail password there's
an overabundance of info dump scenes
where characters just tell Hanks what he
needs to know he's supposed to be this
very smart guy who figures out riddles
and it's one of the most compelling
things about his character but in this
movie with his memory loss they take
that away so he's kind of just like this
bumbling somewhat handsome older man
who's running around Florence with
Felicity Jones the best part of this
movie is Irfan Khan he is the most
entertaining character he gave the most
compelling performance he's barely in
the movie unfortunately the most
disappointing thing for me about this
movie is actually not Ron Howard's
direction which I really did not enjoy
but it was David Koepp script I am
always pulling for this guy he's written
some of my favorite movies he's directed
some movies I really like like stir of
echoes I enjoy secret window it's not
perfect but I enjoy it ghost town
premium rush his script takes so long to
give Felicity Jones a reason to be with
Hanks in this movie for a very long time
she's just the girl who runs around and
goes hey I like that stuff when I was a
kid and you like it too so let's run
around and flee from bullets because I'm
a nurse
even worse our revelations that come
forth in the third act that make
everything else that came before it
incredibly contrived nothing makes sense
anymore it's the type of plot reveal
that thinks wow because this is so
unexpected well this is just good right
you're going to be blown away because
you didn't expect this you can see this
coming
well sure Darth Vader could take his
helmet off and Princess Leia could be
under there
that would be unexpected doesn't mean
it's good and if that plot revealed
didn't take the movie there's another
one after that makes it even worse it's
the kind of script that keeps in every
scene like hey you didn't expect that
did you oh you didn't see that one oh
guess what that thing you didn't expect
well that's not even that it's something
else
I got you towards the end of this film I
was silently willing the screen to fade
to credits I just wanted this movie to
end for me personally this is the worst
type of bad movie it's not so bad that
it's good you can't laugh at it it's not
80 or 90 minutes long so it's not over
quick it's like two hours is boring and
dull and there's nothing entertaining
about it Tom Hanks is trying that's the
only positive I could find while
thinking about Inferno which is a film
that discusses the topic of Hell quite
often my vision of Hell is being forced
to watch inferno on multiple repeats I'm
going to give this film a d-minus simply
because Tom Hanks was trying and I felt
bad for him in every scene it seemed
like everything surrounding him was just
failing while he was actually trying
whyyy I didn't expect it to be that bad
I was like I'm not really that excited
for it but that truly shocked me that
just took me off-guard completely I do
have some good news though my promotion
with Squarespace is continuing if you
guys go to squarespace.com slash Chris
Stockman and use the offer code stuckman
you can get 10% off a website that you
can build yourself web design is
actually how I started I used to build
my own website at the library and I did
movie reviews and it led me to this so
if you guys are interested in starting
your own website in which you can build
and deliver your own content for your
eventual followers I think Squarespace
is a really good place to start they
have beautiful and intuitive design
templates they have a lot of really
great options at your disposal it's also
very easy to use and they have 24/7
customer support which I did not have
when I started so that is a big plus
because there were a lot of times I was
like what am I even doing right now
and by far the best plus is that if you
sign up for a year you get a free domain
name for a year that is a great great
plus so if you go to Squarespace comm
slash Chris stuckman and use my name
stuckman you get 10% off thank you so
much guys for watching I hope you take
advantage of that offer you guys are the
best and if you like this you can click
right here and get stuck mine eyes
[Music]